Is Donald Trump on his way to becoming
the world's chief defender of
Christianity? That's what various media
have been reporting. One Fox News
headline asserts that Trump is quote
vowing to defend the Christian faith.
These claims trace back to a White House
statement released on Palm Sunday, April
13th, where Donald Trump spoke of Jesus
Christ in Easter or Resurrection Sunday
in terms that would edify the most
faithful of Christians. Here are a few
snippets from Trump's statement. Quote,
"This Holy Week, Melania and I join in
prayer with Christians celebrating the
crucifixion and resurrection of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ, the living son
of God, who conquered death, freed us
from sin, and unlocked the gates of
heaven for all of humanity. This week is
a time of reflection for Christians to
memorialize Jesus's crucifixion, and to
prepare their hearts, minds, and souls
for his miraculous resurrection from the
dead. In his final hours on earth,
Christ willingly endured excruciating
pain, torture, and execution on the
cross out of a deep and abiding love for
all his creation. Through his suffering,
we have redemption. Through his death,
we are forgiven of our sins. Through his
resurrection, we have hope of eternal
life. On Easter morning, the stone is
rolled away. The tomb is empty and light
prevails over darkness, signaling that
death does not have the final word. Wow.
Whoever thought you'd hear an American
president speak like that. As evangelist
Franklin Graham observed, quote,
"Trump's proclamation is historic, and
there has not been in my lifetime a
president that has communicated the
gospel as clearly as he has. He's not a
preacher, but in this proclamation, he
gave one of the best sermons for Easter
that many pastors will give from the
pulpit, including some who won't."
"Donald Trump is not afraid of his
faith," continues Graham. "He's not
ashamed of his faith, and he's willing
to let the world know it." For those
familiar with the preuncter
proclamations of previous
administrations, it's hard to deny
Graham's logic. As for Trump's vow to
defend Christianity, here is the
relevant excerpt from the same
proclamation from the president's Palm
Sunday proclamation. Quote, "This Holy
Week, my administration renews its
promise to defend the Christian faith in
our schools, military, workplaces,
hospitals, and halls of government. We
will never waver in safeguarding the
right to religious liberty, upholding
the dignity of life and protecting God
in our public square. Very interesting.
But does all this make Trump a bonafide
defender of Christianity, a defensor
feday, defender of the faith, an athleta
Christi, champion of Christ, or even a
mischiev of Christ? All epithets used to
describe the great heroes of Christian
history. As the author of a book called
Defenders of the West, the Christian
Heroes who stood against Islam, and as
someone who has closely researched the
historic defense of Christianity, I am,
I think, rather qualified to answer this
question. So, lend me your ear. A great
many of the defenders I have read and
wrote about were like Trump, leaders of
men, counts, kings, and even emperors.
However, unlike Trump, these men were
also warriors whose defense of
Christendom usually culminated with
their taking to the field of battle and
often being at the very center of the
fray. Many of them died fighting for the
faith. While this may suggest that Trump
is not a defender of Christianity, we
still have not accounted for context for
time and place. The defenders I write of
lived in a time when battle was
necessary, when the enemy, in this case
Muslims, were always at the gate and in
need of being repulsed, sword in hand.
Our times are obviously different. Sure,
Muslims are still terrorizing Europeans,
but that's not because they are invading
Europe, but rather because Europe's
ruling elite are allowing them in and
enabling them against the native once
Christian population, which is a whole
other bizarre topic with no historic
precedent. In America, however, which is
still nominally Christian, there are few
physical attacks against Christianity,
which would naturally require a physical
defense, the sort which the defenders of
the West historically resorted to. There
are, to be sure, many attacks on
churches, which are obviously physical,
but they are already illegal and have
law enforcement to contend with. In
short, Christianity in America need not
be defended by force because the attacks
on it are not by force. Rather, attacks
on Christianity, and these are many, are
insidious and subtle. They revolve
around entrenched policies, practices,
and conduct. As such, a defense of equal
kind and measure, not one with swords
and spears, is required. And to this
end, the Trump administration is
delivering. Thus, two months before his
recent Easter proclamation on February
6, 2025, Trump signed an executive order
establishing a task force to end the
anti-Christian weaponization of
government and unlawful conduct
targeting Christians. According to a
White House statement, which continues
as follows, quote, "The task force,
officially known as the task force to
eradicate anti-Christian bias, will
review the activities of all departments
and agencies to identify and eliminate
anti-Christian policies, practices, or
conduct. It will identify and address
gaps in laws and enforcement that have
contributed to anti-Christian conduct.
The previous administration engaged in
an egregious pattern of targeting
peaceful Christians while ignoring
violent anti-Christian offenses.
President Trump will not tolerate this
abuse of government and is taking action
to ensure that any unlawful and improper
anti-Christian conduct policies or
practices are identified, terminated,
and rectified. The illusion to the
previous Biden administration is
especially apt for our discussion of
context and times. The following are
among the many anti-Christian measures
that took place under the Biden
administration. Quote, "The Biden
Department of Justice brought felony
charges and obtained multi-year prison
sentences against nearly two dozen
pro-life Christians for praying and
peacefully demonstrating outside
abortion facilities. The Biden
Department of Justice ignored hundreds
of attacks on Catholic churches,
charities, and pro-life centers. In
2023, a Federal Bureau investigation
memo asserted that traditional Catholics
were domestic terrorism threats and
suggested infiltrating Catholic churches
as threat mitigation. The Biden
Department of Education sought to repeal
religious liberty protections for
faith-based organizations on college
campuses. The Biden Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission sought to force
Christians to affirm radical transgender
ideology against their faith. and the
Biden Department of Health and Human
Services sought to drive Christians out
of the foster care system. Even in the
context of Easter, the Biden
administration made it a point to mock
Christianity. If Trump just vocally and
unabashedly proclaimed Christ's
resurrection in 2025, in 2024, the Biden
administration declared resurrection
Sunday as transgender day of visibility.
So yes, all things being equal and in
the context of the times and
circumstances, Trump is a defender of
Christianity. When compared to his
contemporaries, Trump's words and deeds
are arguably even more impressive than
those of history's Christian defenders
when compared to their contemporaries.
But of course, that too is a sign of the
times. Almost all preodern Christians
were ready to fight for their faith,
meaning the overall standard bar was
much higher then.